[Musique]
un court moment d'insouciance pour ses
enfants du camp de moi ramadi aa phryne
pour eux pas de masque ni de mesure de
distance à sion sociale les conditions
de vie et de survie constituent les
urgences du moment conditions d'hygiène
promiscuité manque de moyens la pandémie
qui fait rage dans le pays menace de se
propager encore plus rapidement dans ces
camps aux conditions sanitaires
dramatique à offrir le nombre total de 4
coronavirus est de 1600 à l'hôpital à
cette année si on se prépare à une
flambée des cas ces dernières semaines
il a eu beaucoup de cas mais maintenant
c'est beaucoup mieux
si la situation est particulière à
phryne dans le reste du pays c'est la
même chose
l'aide médicale peine régulièrement
arrivé mardi human rights watch a
souligné l'importance de la distribution
du vaccin dans le pays
les organismes qui comptent fournir à la
syrie des vaccins contre le coc u19
devrait s'assurer autant que possible
que ces vaccins puisse parvenir aux
personnes les plus vulnérables ou
qu'elle soit dans le pays fin janvier le
gouvernement syrien a approuvé son
adhésion au système kovacs mise en place
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
tout en soulignant que cela ne devrait
pas porter atteinte à la souveraineté du
pays
le pays déplore un peu plus de 14 mille
deux cents cas pour 930 décès depuis le
début de la pandémie
selon le ministère syrien de la santé